welcome to a lab roots webinar hosted
by kai jin and sponsored by kaijin today
we have an expert panel
uh with a really interesting uh
discussion powering the precision in
precision medicine the role of curated
data
databases and knowledge my name is
dominic john
i lead up the marketing and the clinical
product management team
at kaijun digital insights i'll be your
mc
today
if we look at the topic of today i want
to really question and how do we enable
precision
in precision medicine it was interesting
in november i got to see a report
from a survey sponsored by genomeweb
the interesting sort of factor there was
we're asking molecular pathologists who
were doing
next generation sequencing you know what
was their confidence
in interpreting their their patient
results here looking at those variants
from their ngs tests and what really
sort of shocked me and surprised me
was the fact that over 45 percent of
those who asked
said they rated their confidence in
interpretation
uh less than seven out of ten uh you
know
to me you know that means we've got a
long way to go really to deliver on that
precision medicine
and one of the big questions is you know
where is that confidence and we we've
seen some interesting results as to what
was driving that confidence
and i think a large part of that is
access to high quality
knowledge and what we want to do today
in this
webinar here is use our expert panel to
help the audience here
understand some of the emerging
challenges in genomic testing for
somatic
and hereditary diseases and then you
know very importantly
let's look at the role of curated
knowledge bases to support that and
improve that confidence
and deliver that precision but
recognizing at the same time there's
lots of different
knowledge sources out there different
databases they're curated in different
ways
and you have a lot of choices so this
webinar will
help you and the panel will help you
work out you know what are the right
sources of information
for you so let's uh introduce our
panelists here
uh we've got uh three great panelists uh
they all come
with long experience in the industry
here building uh
databases presenting databases uh that
support our next generation clinical uh
interpretation so maybe what we'll do
here is just have each of the panelists
introduce themselves give a little bit
of background and then what i'd like to
do is each them talk about
their products and their subject matter
expertise here
so uh lisa why don't you go first why
don't you give us a little bit of
background about yourself
sure thanks dominic so um i'm lisa
barlang and i am a senior
application scientist here at kaiogen i
have more than 15 years of experience
working in the field of oncology and
rare diseases
and i spent over five years as a variant
scientist
generating clinical reports so currently
at kyogen i do serve as a scientific
liaison
frequently delivering workshops
trainings and demonstrations on our
informatics solutions to directors and
genetic counselors
and i also can assist with serving as a
consultant really to help our customers
understand
what is the best secondary and tertiary
analysis solutions to support their
various tests
including heretic cancer panels and kind
of collect stones
fantastic thank you sir simon i wouldn't
give us a bit of background in yourself
i'm gonna sound fairly similar i'm simon
forbes
i'm at the saga institute with the
delightful title of head of cosmic
which means i run the cosmic
product and project at the sanger
institute
i've been in cancer
maybe five years or more both at
cambridge university and the sanger
institute
and um we're really looking to make sure
cosmic doesn't just detail all of the
mutations
uh in in human cancer but really makes
that data
accessible and easy to use and really
very valuable
in the pursuit of precision oncology
fantastic
thanks simon and then sean hi
hi i'm excuse me sean bauer i'm a
director of content engineering at
kyogen
um i'm responsible for team
two main teams the team of scientists
who
work on uh curation and ensuring that
the
content that we curate gets um
goes into our applications and is used
appropriately and then a group of
knowledge engineers and
bio uh bioinformaticists who
work on the knowledge modeling and
ensuring that process
flows smoothly prior to that i worked in
drug discovery
in a variety of areas so it's a area
i've been familiar with for
quite a while um on uh different uh you
know
two different sites one on the discovery
of the drug discovery side and now
the use of the drugs in clinical
applications
fantastic so you know from the audience
perspective we've got three
great panelists here with deep
experience in
creating building knowledge bases and
providing knowledge bases
across both the somatic and hereditary
domain both in i should say research and
the clinical setting
uh here so to sort of move the
conversation forward here i'd like each
of those
panelists to introduce their products
and their the line of expertise
and then after that we'll go through
some questions here around some of the
trends they're seeing
uh some of the challenges that people
are addressing and then how does the
content and what to look for in the
content
uh here so maybe at least um why don't
you sort of lead off here with
uh your uh your background in the
products that you represent
sure absolutely so today i would like to
just share a bit about
um human gene mutation database or hdmd
professional
we have you know been selling this
product for
an extended period but there's a lot
that i would like to share with you
about
hgmd so essentially if you're
doing any type of hereditary
interpretation um whether for clinical
cases or in the research
arena you're probably familiar with hgmd
because it really is considered to be
the best tool for answering questions
around
you know what is the impact of this
mutation in terms of causing hereditary
diseases
hdmd is curated explicitly from
peer-reviewed published
journals so we do have a team of
scientists
that are manually creating the
information from the literature
and it's truly an expert curated
database
it only contains germline mutations so
you would not see any somatic mutations
there and
i think while it is extensively used
what is really it is renowned for is
that it is a gold standard
and that's because of the quality of the
content and the rigor
of the qa that has gone into this work
to ensure that it is indeed
accurate and consistent um so i used
hcmd
extensively i was a very scientist for
about five years
and in the clinical lab it was certainly
the go-to for us to
detect alterations and help to
understand the
uh causal variants in rare disorders
and what we're hearing our customers say
is that they're saving 50 percent of
time
when they use hdmd compared to methods
that they were
using prior to adopting hcmd in their
laboratory so in terms of
these curation source we are partnering
with
the institute of medical genetics at
cardiff university they have established
a database
over 25 years ago so again just having
that
extensive experience in doing germline
curation
so in terms of the publication rate
um as scientists were very aware that
you know every day there are you know
hundreds of publications
that are released so um being a variant
scientist
it's very hard to figure out what is the
pertinent
publication for any genes or variants
so hcmd is able to save you time because
it has
this comprehensive database whereby you
can just go to htmd
readily search for a gene or for a
variant or
phenotype and be able to take advantage
of the more than 127
000 articles that have been manually
created
in hdmd additionally our
genetic experts or scientists are highly
trained many of them
have been with the company for more than
or the university for more than five
years on average
so they're really very familiar with
getting to
the key findings from the publication
and ensuring that it is accurately
curated
additionally we are doing quarterly uh
releases of hcmd
and what that does for you is that it
really ensures that you have
uh up-to-date content so as of now
if you can see this uh this graph here
you can see that
you know over the last decade or so
there's uh steep inclined hair in terms
of the amount of
disease causing mutations that have been
catalogued in hdmd
with no more than 300 000 mutations
being available
so we wanted to discuss a bit about the
uses of hdmd so we did do a recent
survey and we found that you know if you
were to use google scholar there are
more than 17 000
published studies that have referenced
hdmd because they've pulled key
information
an agency fight causal variants from
using hdmd
when we asked our clients watered key
uses
and use cases they shared that hdmd is
very
relevant in terms of being able to help
them to search for mutations to search
for genes
and diseases but also being able to
enable them to do advanced
searches across different mutation types
or characteristics
and then because we do have uh
availability for the download option
many of our customers are actually
downloading the data from hdmd
and incorporating it into their own
analysis pipelines
additionally they've found that with
hdmd they can readily
design different panels of interest and
they're able to as well prioritize
mutations so it is really a robust
database that can be used in many
different ways
to really help you to get to an answer
or to again build out those internal
pipelines
so i just mentioned the ability to
download
we do have that available i just want to
differentiate
hdmd because as an application scientist
i often
will hear from you know some customers
um isn't hdmd
free so we do all for hdmd public
which is um free to academic users
and so again you know having been in
grad school you might have heard of hdmd
even use that publicly available
uh site but the issue there is that that
content is
three years away from where we are with
the current standard
so in order to get the most up-to-date
content you would have to subscribe to
hdmd professional
and there you can go to the web
application and conduct those searches
and queries
again on the gene level the alteration
level or diseases
but you also have the ability to be able
to download
with another subscription the content
from hdmd professional
so this may be a little bit small this
table but it's really just going over
uh several of the different types of
searches that are available for you
essentially the key point here is that
for public you have a limitation in
terms of the amount of search
and queries that you can perform as
compared to hdmd professional
where you can see you do have a full
functionality
across the board to search across
various different attributes whether
you're interested in
searching on variant classes or various
ontologies or understanding
genome sequence information that's all
available to you
in hdmd professional so with that
i'll pause there so we can discuss some
of our other databases
fantastic so what had great background
there lisa
let's move into simon to give us a bit
of background on the somatic side so
simon if you want to just lead away so
um
i'm going to present cosmic
in a similar way to hgmd is a genotype
phenotype relationship database
across the somatic mutations in cancer
so we're focused on
human cancer and we're focused on the 90
percent of mutations
that drive cancer by acquisition across
a lifetime's exposure to a variety of
carcinogenic effects and the idea in
cosmic is
similar to hdmd we will capture
information
from a wide variety of sources primarily
the literature
but also the the expanding range of
international genome consortium
producing
huge genome-wide content across cancer
we'll standardize that in a variety of
forms integrate it
and annotate it in in standard ways
and kind of make that available in a
wide variety of
different forms for for integration or
analysis in
in a number of different ways the data
in cosmic
is curated primarily by hand
using two related pathways
on the left hand side large-scale
genomic data
usually comes along with a human genome
coordinates and can be annotated for
genetic consequence
using a database like ensemble and the
hundreds of thousands or sometimes
tens of millions of mutations coming out
of
cancer genomes get annotated in that
fashion
but the majority of uh
very cancer gene specific information
uh going into cosmic is hand curated
we've got a team of curators who are
experts in their field with previous
scientific expertise
and they they look at the literature
for the genes that we know drive cancer
and they can
tease out all of the detailed bits of
information
[Music]
also i froze for a second there
they're teasing out not just the
mutations that are driving disease but
also
the the the disease descriptions
themselves
at high resolution and the idea is to
not just be very specific about the
mutation but also the disease
and that's where you'll get the most
significant genotype phenotype
relationships which mutations are
driving which disease
the broad genomic data from the uh from
the big wide studies is merged with the
the real deep insights we get from these
gene by genes assessments
and they form the basis of the cosmic
database
and the idea go into cosmic
you can you can immediately discover
which mutations are significant in which
disease
and i'm just comparing two visions of
the ketonku gene here
and on the left you can see a fairly
rare blood cancer marcel neoplasm is
clearly driven by
a single nucleotide variant uh resulting
in
a d816v change in the phosphotransferase
domain
and on the right hand side there's a
much broader range
of mutations driving a gastrointestinal
tumor
there's a little bit of d816 feed but
there's a much broader range of
substitutions and also a much higher
number
of deletions and
looking at this scale of database in
this resolution
uh you you can really see which
mutations
are driving this disease but also how
they change across genes
and across diseases and of course it's
this information that's essential
to uh which which targets are
appropriate in pharmaceutical design
which ones
are useful and how do you characterize
them which biomarkers are important
not just how do you annotate diagnostic
reports but how do you explore them from
a vus perspective which ones
can you give some information if you
don't quite know
what it's trying to tell you and looking
at
cosmic and leading on from cosmic we
released last year
the cancer mutation census this is a
tier on top of cosmic
that details a wide variety of
population and biological and other
observation
properties across each mutation in
cosmic
and this gives you a good way to
navigate every single mutation in cosmic
from a variety of perspectives to not
just identify which mutations
we know matter in disease but which ones
have uh potentially oncogenic properties
that allow you to to navigate their
uncertain status if it's a vus a variant
of unknown significance how do you
interpret it
and the cancer mutation census gives you
lots of information
to support that interpretation
and and our latest
release a few weeks ago
included a new component of cosmic uh on
mutation actionability
and this is not just all the
observations of mutations in cancer not
just the properties
that allow you to evaluate which
mutations are important in cancer
but this is a very um strong list
of which mutations are actionable which
mutations
can you treat with which drug in which
disease
and with what survivability metrics this
is curated primarily from the literature
using
follow-up studies from clinical trials
and a variety of other literature
um exploring the consequence of treating
various cancers with mutations with a
variety of drugs
and this gives you really good ways of
navigating uh
how to apply precision oncology um in a
clinical audience
thank you all right fantastic simon so
we've got lisa representing uh the
hereditary side with hdmd
and then cosmic on the oncology uh let's
hear from sean who's actually got uh
probably a bit of both but let's hear
um yeah so let me jump in here i'm going
to talk a little more about
um the i'm going to talk about the the
focus of this will be the kyogen
knowledge base which is our repository
of
of information um which then goes out to
uh power our content based applications
such as ipa
qci qci qc sorry qca
kaiogen clinical insight interpret that
would be both a hereditary and somatic
workflows so
um our curation process is uh
this is similar in some ways to what
simon described
um so at a high level we start with
unstructured data
and then also structured data for
unstructured that would be
um we'll need to identify articles that
would
would be expected to have content
relevant to our applications these are
primarily uh articles from the primary
literature
can also be clinical trials drug labels
clinical practice guidelines and things
like that
these are then manually curated using
our trained scientists and our curation
tools and then
um imported so that we've then
transformed that unstructured
information from those
documents and other sources into
information that's structured and thus
computationally accessible for
structured imports that's a little bit
easier in some ways we take
structured information such as tables or
xml
things of that sort from from various
sources
input map them to our our the concepts
that represent the same thing in our
knowledge base
and then um import those both of these
are done
um as as you know imported and updated
as
you know to keep the content current as
each you know subsequent release of
of a database that we've licensed gets
updated we then import that content into
our knowledge base
and in many cases put it out as part of
our our
weekly content updates so the the kind
of the fundamental point behind that is
to take unstructured and structured data
um and integrate it all within one
common framework so that it can all be
used
essentially interchangeably and that
that requires you know the translation
of the information in
transformation into our framework um of
course testing looking for consistencies
inconsistencies and of course then
export into our applications and then
once that goes into our applications
like ingenuity pathway analysis
or hygiene clinical insight that's when
it leads to
you know that makes makes it then
becomes useful for more useful i guess
for the customers so one of the um
fundamental points of the information
that we capture is um
is is its highly detailed nature and
it's highly
um the how highly accessible that
those details are within our findings so
um
when our scientists uh curate
information from the
from these sources um you know such as a
here's an example of a drug approval
from some time ago
where each of the elements of this
finding
are essentially mapped to concepts
within our knowledge base and then
and then thus become accessible so for
example the drug has been approved to
prevent skeletal related events
associated with bone metastases and a
human with a solid tumor each of those
elements
then can be accessed and used in our
applications which has
proven really useful um in in the
the space of the of qci especially
around qci somatic as
drugs have as drug approvals have
evolved and the uses of them have become
more refined
there's more and more detail that we've
been capturing along the way which has
proven useful for um you know creating
clarity for the various customers so
i think that's something that's going to
continue to be a challenge as we as we
move forward is
as the biomarkers become more
complicated or the combination of
biomarkers for a given indication for
example
uh as that expands and the various use
cases expand that richness uh
serves as well the scale of that content
um is is quite large we've been curating
information
for into our knowledge base for over 20
years
um that's resulted in well over 20
million findings that includes manually
curated information as well as the
database imports
for just as a slice of that we have over
33 000 disease
various disease classes and subclasses
covered
that results in over a billion edges
within our knowledge base this is
comprised of over
80 850 000 references and greater than
35
integrated scientific and clinical
databases
our knowledge base contains over 3
million biological concepts and
as i said we're doing these updates
essentially daily so we
have greater than about greater than 5
000 new data elements and findings are
imported per day
that content then um goes out to our
various applications
along you know along standard updates
and then is you know used by our users
that's it
all right fantastic uh thank you uh sean
just to to um you know just a sort of
person with
perspective there sean correct me if i'm
wrong i think the knowledge base here
has been used to process over 16 million
cases genomic profiling
sorry that audio broke up just a bit
there could you repeat
yeah so i believe the knowledge base has
been used to process over 2 million
patient cases for genomic profiling
today
is that correct yes i believe that's
true yes yeah
all right so you know just summary here
sort of three uh experts here three
different sort of
you know products that are delivering
knowledge here
uh what i'd like to do now is really get
into a q a session and start uh
drilling down and extracting some
expertise and some guidance from the
the panelists here so really i think
you know step back a little bit and you
know let's look at the
trends before we talk about you know the
the what and the how
but you know let's step back and look at
the the trends that are impacting
genomic profiling
uh clinical testing here so to the
panelists
here what do you see as the major trends
in
uh next generation 16 testing and then
you know what uh what how is that sort
of
affecting interpretation so anyone
feel free to answer sure
so i would say um you know having worked
with uh several
uh hereditary testing labs over the last
few years what i'm seeing
happening more over the last year is
that
more customers are interested in looking
at copy number changes
so c and b's and that is something that
i think ngs before there were some
limitations there but more and more labs
are you know
venturing into doing copy number
analysis
and of course once you have those
detections you need to be able to
understand
what it actually means um to that
specific heritage cancer
or specific disorder so it's important
more and more
to also capture the structural variants
and look at the impact of that from the
literature
we are also seeing i believe more tumor
normal testing
as a norm um in our clients
doing those types of applications as
well as looking very closely at
panels for cardiomyomyopathy and
alzheimer's as well
so that's something that i think is
much more adopted recently and we have a
lot of curation for that
in hdmd as well
all right simon you know what's really
yeah
stalling on from lease i agree that um
there's there's more to it than the dna
seek um
dna sequence would be the major way that
it interpreted
uh this information and but there's
there's
there are many more mutation mechanisms
especially in cancer
just looking at it from a cancer
perspective that a driving disease and
then anything
a simple dna seek test can can reveal so
while we've got
in cosmic i think it's just over 30
million mutations
we've actually got 70 odd million um
somatic variants encompassing a wide
variety of
different mutation mechanisms and just
looking through the kind of thing that
you see
people uh navigating precision oncology
by
um if if you have a
lung cancer with an egfr mutation
standard procedure would
be to give a drug called deficient but
as
the cancer evolves uh quite often a
t790m mutation results in
resistance to that drug therefore you
need a new drug something like
autoimmune and there's this this kind of
constant evolution that you can assess
by
dna seek but but that evolution needs to
be watched it's not a single one process
anymore
and then beyond that um
the the the uh the mutation status
of or the inactivation status of um
genes is very important to know if you
have an atm
gene in activation you get a good
response to radiotherapy
if you don't have that inactivation then
radiotherapy might not be the way to go
with the patient
similarly if you inactivate braca
you get a good response to drugs that
inhibit dna repair and there's a there's
a great way of putting together a number
of
different uh molecular mechanisms um
and mutations all of which can appear
independently to
begin to frame a really accurate picture
of how to treat any individual patient
all right thanks simon and sean yeah i i
absolutely on the in the somatic space
simon summed it up very nicely
um i um in the time that i've been
working on this
um you know when we when we first
started qci even
i mean obviously before it was released
when it was in wireframes
um there were only a handful of drugs
that on their
uh on the the indicate on the label had
a
a biomarker as a um as as a prerequisite
for using the drug and
uh gefetniv being one of the very early
ones and then as time has evolved
there's
multiple egfr inhibitors and then the
way those get targeted and used and then
especially around patients that have
undergone multiple lines of therapy
so they may start with cafeteria then
they go into osimertinib and then
there's another change and another
change
and tracking those things and then and
and making
and then as as people continue to do um
clinical trials and
and various other studies that get
reported understanding what is the
so in taking that cancer sample uh you
know that ngs sample and
and also it's been tested in non-ngs
ways and taking all of that
that input from that describes the tumor
and synthesizing it into
you know one one system where it can you
can generate a report from that
and then taking the complexity of all
that's changing within the literature
and trying to come up with the right
therapy or the right possible
therapeutic recommendations for them
um yeah it's becoming increasingly
increasingly complicated so
um you know anything that we can do to
to
move that forward and make use of the
information from the literature and
present it to the clinicians
um you know quickly and in a way that's
easily under
understandable is is going to be really
valuable and it's becoming
and it's interesting i mean as when we
first started the notion of biomarkers
and combination biomarkers so
you know the patient that has t790m plus
l838 for example
knowing that that's a resist you know
well they're sensitized to gephetine but
it's also resistant
that's a very simple case and i mean
that one's been around for a while but
that exists for
for many different uh drugs now it makes
it very challenging so
essentially you guys all jumped on sort
of the complexity of
the cases we're looking at precision
medicine and now there's all these sort
of external pieces of information that
help you with that new sort of decision
which goes back to that originals for
point of confidence it's getting more
and more challenging from that
perspective
but uh you didn't comment on you know
panels and whole genome whole exome
i mean what sort of trends are you
seeing there in terms of uptake of
panel size and whole genome like exome
do you want to comment
yeah so i'm certainly seeing um whole
atom and whole genome sequencing
being done more often i think there are
still
um for some of our clients issues around
reimbursement
and so you know it might be the case
that
virtual panels might be an approach that
is used
also some of the panels that are
available when you start to
look at the smaller panels for
alzheimer's or parkinson's
um it's not clear just from the vendors
why those jeans are on the panel so back
to the confidence of that
being able to use a database like hdmd
where you can really query across
the phenotype or disease and see all of
the evidence just at your fingertips
and that has been really helpful towards
you know allowing our customers to have
more confidence in the panel testing
that they are doing
but clinical axon is something that is
being onboarded more
frequently just again with some of the
complexity of okay
how do i get this reimbursed and then
what does all the data mean and that's
why
it's just so important to be able to
leverage the content in
the databases that we're discussing
yeah i agree um it's it's still fairly
recent that we're having conversations
with people on which 17 genes we should
be testing across hematological cancers
um
17 genes feels like a tiny number of
genes to be testing these days but of
course
it's possible to recommend for reasons
of scale you want to
ask a all 700 genes that may be enrolled
in cancer
um but then you're getting towards very
large panels and exomes
the the and and we do talk to people who
are doing exams and genomes and there's
a lot of discovery behind that
but of course there's a lot of
complexity in its uh interpretation
when you do a genome analysis of a tumor
versus a normal
you'll find tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands sometimes millions of
mutations
somatic mutations most of which are a
consequence of disease
rather than driving the disease and most
of which aren't treatable in any sense
whatsoever
um and i think the there's a slight
theory in exomes and genomes
that you're also going to find
incidental findings um
is there something in there that might
misdirect treatment
so uh having accurate information on
what is significant in test design what
should i be looking for and what
shouldn't i be looking for
is essential in navigating this really
complex process
yeah and something i think you're sort
of you know actually just to reflect on
the conversation here about the trends
it's really two things we're seeing
the diversity and the complexity of the
decisions that have to be made
and the second one is you know there's
progression from these smaller targeted
panels to larger targeted to whole exome
and obviously that creates a whole set
of new challenges especially when it
comes to interpretation precision
medicine and
confidence so maybe let's you know move
to the second one
so from an interpretation a confidence
precision that's in perspective
what do you see are the challenges that
are now being faced by these
you know labs or research organizations
adopting ngs in the clinical world
lisa yeah definitely i feel surprising
but
yeah no certainly it's um you know the
clinical guidelines right so
they are you know ever evolving clinical
guidelines are coming out there are some
that are more standard like the acmg
um guidelines but even recently you know
there was an updated paper on
how to for instance classify those cnbs
right
and um being able to not just read
understand digest that information but
then know how to incorporate that in
terms of you know the
identification of pathogenicity of a
particular variant or whether it would
cause
disease um that can also be very very
challenging so you know it's really
great that not only
in hdmd for instance you have the
ability to understand
what that underlying evidence is and all
the references that support
the classification of the variant but
you know they do have very well
structured
ways of categorizing all the variants so
that you can get a sense for you know
what is actually causing a disease
versus what is perhaps just a very of
unknown significance or uncertain
significance and additionally
in hdmd it is really just germline
mutations
so that's very helpful for hereditary
labs that aren't distracted with other
types of alterations that
are not important for hereditary
diseases
and beyond that you don't have any
polymorphisms
so i think one of the challenges that
labs are facing is
you know how to really incorporate the
guidelines so that they're sure they're
accurately
classifying the variants and then stay
on top of all of the
new changes that are coming out to the
various guidelines as well
yeah oh i think simon was
focused
i'll let you go first oh i i was just
you know kind of following up on that i
um i think
i think that um especially as we move on
to
larger and larger panels um well
actually when i see the larger and
larger panels i typically think of the
content acquisition side
the challenges of doing that making sure
we have the appropriate content and then
of course
providing it to the users in a way where
it'll be you know clear and
understandable um and especially
filtering through
um the the variants that are that are
going to have an effect and drive the
disease versus ones that are passengers
or
you know less relevant um and so you
know
it's one thing to you know run a bigger
panel and get more information and
that's obviously going to be very
very helpful especially in areas where
you are looking for you know maybe a
rare variant which is leading to the
disease but
but then understanding how to take that
variant amongst all of the others and
understand that that's the variant
that's the driver
and that is relevant making use of the
information from the literature
and any kind of prediction algorithms we
can use it just
it seems to be that's when i look at
these those are the challenges that that
i don't know
kind of make me a little nervous let's
say um because we'll have to you know
one can you know expand our content
acquisition find the variance in
literature
but also integrate them in a way that
that makes them actionable because
it's you know having more data is a good
thing but
you have to you know have an insight
from that data and and
um you know have and be able to
understand what
what it actually means and what the next
step would be as far as
you know predicting the risk of disease
and the hereditary workflow
or you know what the next therapeutic
option is or what the
you know the estimated you know what
effect it would have on the patient's
prognosis
so um i i don't know but i'm a little
less on the the customer
facing an app side a little more on the
content and the engineering side so
my perspective i think might be a little
different that way so
yeah i definitely agree i think it
wasn't that long ago when people had a
look of panic in their faces when you're
having a conversation with them
around navigating hundreds of thousands
of mutations per
genome um and the expectation was we'd
get to
large scale ngs at least exomes to to
to really understand what the genomics
was behind any individual patient's
cancer
but which mutations actually matter
rather than which mutations are there is
is a real challenge
and as everyone's saying
are various levels of uncertainty around
uh
much variant interpretation and how much
information can you bring to support
that
evaluation is is so important now
because
we can rattle off a number of mutations
that we know drive cancer and you can
say kit
you can say egfr you can say k raz but
underneath that if you're looking at
between five and ten drivers per cancer
um with a continually evolving
resistance mechanism to any individual
therapeutic intervention then there is a
continual almost requirement on
mutation interpretation the more
information you can throw at that the
better
and then of course trying to keep up to
date with which drugs do
useful things to particular patients
with particular diseases with particular
mutations
is is is a big complex challenge to keep
up to date with
and i think beyond the or within the
three of our resources
hopefully we're really looking to
provide solutions across
the majority of those questions yeah
yeah so
yeah if you want to already you know
just the volume of data but also the
timeliness of the the data as well as
his key
it was interesting i was you know
personal experience here i was talking
to a clinical lab and
you know they were saying you know
they've just moved up to a 500 gene
panel for
cancer and they were taking you know on
average
six hours a uh case to interpret
and you know this is that we can't scale
um you know
there was just share a volume of you
know content and information that they
have to go researched
before they felt confident in delivering
that report
so you know really moving this on i mean
you know maybe you know flip around i've
heard various pieces of this you know do
you want to just summarize well
how do our knowledge bases how do these
knowledge bases help resolve that i mean
i think there's some fairly short
answers to this
uh maybe uh you know simon's gonna go
um so people have been using cosmic for
years to uh to at least uh
annotate uh patient uh
reports and you can begin to say this
this mutation has been seen frequently
therefore it's likely to have
uh some impact but these these sort of
evaluations are more complex than that
so we
that's why we've been putting together
more targeted
bits of cosmic if you like um the cancer
mutation sentence really to add detail
not just has this mutation being seen
frequently but
has it not been seen in in lung cancer
populations has it been seen in disease
specific populations what are its
biological characteristics those sorts
of things that gives you
an idea that it's significant and then
of course beyond that
um from a from a very clinical
perspective not
just which mutation appears to matter
but which mutation can i actually do
something about
i think that that is getting to the crux
of the problem is which mutation can i
do anything about because
while you might have tens of thousands
coming out of an xm if you can't do
anything about anything that looks
significant it doesn't really matter
so what we're doing now is we've we've
got a team of dedicated curators
who are looking at mutation
actionability and
looking across the literature for real
detail
on which mutations are actionable and
what is what is their actionability
which mutation which disease which drug
with survival statistics coming out of
that in detail
to make sure that we can feed um
clinicians high quality useful easily
interpretable data
to uh to navigate patient um
patient treatment because it's a complex
world out there and if we can make it
much more simple
and up to date then hopefully we're
doing a really useful job
yeah yeah that's sorry i totally second
that um
one of the things that as you mentioned
the you have a you know
you run a large panel there are variants
that come in i guess the example you
used was a
case where the scientist was spending
six hours on trying to you know
interpret that variant
and you throw on top of that you know
one of the one of the key sources for
doing that variant interpretation
and and making the the recommendations
of the the treatment options would be
keeping up with the clinical practice
guidelines and um
when you when and then and it's it's in
some areas those clinical
practice guidelines they change quite
dramatically a few times a year so
in addition to that six hours to
interpret that variant they need to go
read the
non-small cell lung practice guideline
which is 200 pages and digest it
that's one of the areas i think where
these software tools are going to be
really valid or i think they are really
valuable and i think that's
always going to that's going to continue
to be the challenge which is to have the
scientists on the
curation teams and the knowledge
modelers etc
get that information curated accurately
put it in an application that where
where the people can have access to it
and then
finally make use of that make make sure
that the content and the decisions that
are
being suggested there the clinical trial
you know recommendations and things like
that are
are up to date and accurate and so they
can be reported out with a
degree of confidence and also making the
the subsequent
information you know easily accessible
because
as detailed as our finding models are
and the findings that hgnd and cosmic
are
you know they came from an article with
many many pages and and
you know we can distill it down very
well and use it effectively but
getting them to the references quickly
so that they can you know
verify for themselves and report it
confidently is
um and that's i think why we do most of
this right to
do that google scholar search or
whatever search they want to do and
you know make it i guess we're down to
six hours it would have been
considerably more than that before but
but kind of but but the complexity seems
to be growing at about the same rate as
our
efficiencies do so maybe we're just
breaking these yeah
so interestingly the uh by using a more
modern approach with uh
you know centralized database and depth
breath quality of information i mean
that lab did actually get down to
an hour hour and a half of that gene
panel but
lisa did you want to comment yeah
definitely i just think um
again just having this experience um
the scientists with more than five years
you know of experience doing the
curation
is is just priceless because they're
able to
really get to the key information very
readily
and then they can you know structure
that content and then
present it in a way that's just easy to
assimilate
right so when you look at hcmd and many
of these other databases as well it's
not only that you have
that human curation being done um that's
saving a tremendous amount of time
but also that it integrates additional
content sources
so in hdmd there are several different
databases that are integrated there such
as prediction
modelers and db smith and others
that allows for you to get that context
of the variant
in hdmd directly without having to waste
time
going separately to all of these
additional
content sources so i can really relate
to the pain of you know taking
hours or seven hours to try to work up a
case
and then just the tremendous time saver
that you have
um having all of that content just
clearly presented to you
and country that you could trust um in a
database
so i mean you know just to summarize
here you know what i'm hearing from all
of you is really
you know what where the the knowledge
bases can really help it's first of all
centralizing but very importantly
it's you know being have the depth
breath and quality
that you can trust um and it's up to
date i mean that's
those are the key elements of what's
needed for a knowledge base that's going
to deal with some of these challenges of
volume and complexity of the the
information i want to move down to you
know helping the audience here
they're looking to you know acquire or
adopt embrace
different tools different software to
support their interpretation
all three of you alluded to um early on
uh some of the the way we uh curate the
information into those knowledge bases
uh would you like to just describe what
are the different approaches
to curation uh there's more automated
there's more with uh you know sort of
manual curation
and then very important i'd like you to
sort of you know say what do you think
of the you know
the positives and the negatives around
this you know
one may be more machine based one may be
more human based maybe a hybrid of both
do you want to just uh comment
yeah so i can start off just um
essentially you know
for hdmd and i think i won't speak for
the other databases here but
you know you do have uh this manual
creation that is being
being done and we're doing the releases
quarterly which again
keeps the content up to date um it is
really great to be able to
you know have scientists but directly at
that literature
find that information i think a strength
of the manual curation is that
you know publications aren't perfect so
there are sometimes errors in the
publication either based on the genomic
mapping that
was done or perhaps a phenotype that was
not reported accurately
and because you have a human doing that
uh
reading and interpretation from the
primary literature
they can actually reach out directly to
the authors of the publication
to clarify anything within that
publication
and certainly our scientists at hcmd
have at cardiff university
they have done that on several occasions
clarifying information
and then authors would then update their
publications
so again you know before we are bringing
it into our database you're having that
additional qc
check so that you really are not then
perpetuating that
error down the line right so i think
that's really a strength
um i i've heard of you know several
other
vendors there and i've used a couple
before um
in in my other roles before i joined
kyogen and i did find that
you get a ton of data but often it was
the case that i was still trying to look
for the needle in the haystack
um so where it might seem like really
great to have like more quantity more
something
simply sounds good it can also still end
up you know
draining some time because it's not
necessarily the the relevant or
pertinent information that you need to
interpret that case
yeah definitely i mean i think you know
obviously there's
completeness of for you know large
amount of data where there's a lot of
false positives a lot of false negatives
that require validation one route the
other one is just you know
more quality trust you know trusted
information uh simon uh
sean do you want a comment but yeah i
think the
emergence of uh x mining type
technologies is very exciting
that can help curation quite a lot
although it's difficult to see it
replacing it any time soon
there are obviously people making text
mining databases out of the literature
and
we compare ourselves to them every now
and again
and while there's a lot of information
there they're hopeful of noise it's
incredible
um it's difficult to find the signal and
as lisa said
the the haystack is gigantic um and i
think
that technology will come to assist
manual curation
but it's difficult to see at least in
the short and medium term that it will
replace it
but there's an additional thing that i
see uh
as a real value of manual curation is
not just being able to
clearly identify the valuable
information and tease it out of this
really complex
language um is is also
the what you might consider more
unexpected points of information
so while we expect a curator to identify
a mutation and a disease to link
together
um there's a lot of information on
a patient's gender
age ethnicity exposure
all of that information that lends
itself very well
to interpreting each of these mutations
and beginning to put together
more useful more accurate patterns of
the genetics behind disease
and i think our curators across the 20
years we've been doing this
you've been teasing out those data
points and now we have a database not
just of mutations against thousands of
diseases
but also several million of these data
points that say
this this gene this mutation was
observed in that disease but also
the the the patient presented in a
particular way or
as a result of therapy the patient
reacted in a certain way and you can
look at sort of
drug response drug resistance
patient journey annotations that really
give you
much greater context around this
information than simple linear patterns
of mutations
sure yeah i i agree entirely i mean i
think
um any type of automation we we have a
lot of our a lot of our our content
acquisition workflow
has is automated we don't start by you
know querying pubmed and these sources
and you know we have we have code to do
these kinds of things and
and like any tool i think that comes out
oftentimes that
there's where you think it may be
someday but then and and it's
you know could it replace could it
replace curation of very simple concepts
that are in articles probably
you know i don't know that we're there
just yet we'll have to learn it and test
it but
um but as we talked about in the first
part of this discussion
is as more and more patients are getting
tested and there are more and more
therapies and
there's more and more this you know
finding the details that are in the you
know in in the various observations
and getting them accurate and correct
you know you kind of get the sense that
maybe ml and ai or nlp processes would
be useful for
the early case when only there was only
gefetniv as an egfr inhibitor
but now that there are multitude it may
get a little bit more difficult so
i think you know like any tool having
being aware of how to use the tool
properly and then
um applying it appropriately so that you
don't overstep that is is always it's a
balance point with any tool and i think
this one is is the same way
the the the libraries that are out there
and and the accessibility to using these
is
has has gone down and uh you know the
the bar is much lower now
um and but one thing also to remember is
that a lot of these things rely upon
training sets
and so that the content that we have
that high level content that's
predominantly manually created with
all that detail and so forth is going to
serve
to train the machine learning algorithms
to
try to extract it so i and and you know
coming up with ways of integrating that
in that
into a manual work workflow i think is
um you know
it's it's going to be similar to the the
more rule-based approaches actually
but um i think everyone who's worked on
this type of thing for a while
is aware of those challenges and
probably you know sees
the same same steps happening only you
know with different tools
yeah you know i think you know going
back to some of the previous challenges
you know the the complexity of all the
interrelated information the fact you're
dealing with
journals publications i fully agree that
ai
and natural language processing is going
to play more and more an important role
in this but
i'm you know i suddenly struggle for the
immediate foreseeable future
how it could replace it it's simply just
because
in science we're so reliant on the
context of a result
you know it can mean two different
things i remember years back um
just looking at a term percent
inhibition with a large pharmaceutical
company we came up with 23 definitions
that we
distinctly unique and that's the size of
the problem we use acronyms left right
and center
which is another sort of challenge that
we have here so i think that human
element of
peer review you know curating the
putting that manual sort of
review on top is so important to the
quality
but ultimately you know what's the
impact of this you know what does it
mean you know
uh of having high quality data i mean do
you want guys want to
your comment in terms of the impact to
the actual person doing the
interpretation what you feel the results
are
yeah i think it can make a tremendous
impact in terms of
patient care right because um several of
our labs they're
doing um some complex testing but also
looking
at rare disorders many times are
impacting pediatric
patients so at the end of the day you
know
we're all here working towards one end i
believe which is to really
impact patient care um so i believe
again
you know it's very important to have a
database that is frequently updated with
the content that you can trust
um just making sure that you have the
quality information
but there are several customers that
have used hdmd
to help them with prioritizing variants
as well and determining
what are lately the causal variants
and that can be really imperative when
you're trying to
again you know have a shorter turnaround
time to be able to give an answer to a
patient that's perhaps on a diagnostic
odyssey and i also want to add that you
know we've talked a bit about pci
interpreting
and the kyogen knowledge base and
there's a interpret has a way of being
able to incorporate
um both hdmv and cosmet or some elements
of it as well so there are ways that you
know
we can really match what is the best
solution that is needed
based on the customer needs
all right thanks i think quality is a
word i'm going to pick up on there and
agree with lisa
that if you don't have a quality
database behind
the starting point of your work it's
very difficult to trust the the
consequence of that work
so so quality is very much
what all our protesters work towards and
that's why
similar to lisa we have long-term
curators with substantial
qc processes and pipelines and
everything to make sure that the data
is well is is is correct and is well
annotated and is
is easily accessible um and that
forms the basis of really accurate
reporting pipelines
or target characterizations and as sean
said
you've got to make sure that your ai is
trained in a really
good fashion with trustworthy data
otherwise your ai
is going to go all over the place so
it's about making sure that the quality
is
the best you can make it it's absolutely
top priority
is the quality of this information trust
the information absolutely
um yeah i i
everything the other two panelists that
i absolutely agree with especially
around quality and
i mean and especially because we are in
a clinical space so
quality is always important customers
expect it the i think collectively the
the expectations of customers has has
gone up
sometimes it seems like a very sharp
slope uh over short durations but
but having the customers expect quality
and i think everyone here
you know has has has mentioned that so
having having that content and and being
able to use it to test and then do other
things and open other doors is
is very valuable but yeah yeah and i'll
go back to the slide that sort of
provoked provoke this conversation here
which is
45 of micropathologists my question said
there was you know seven out of ten or
less confident
and you know i think you got your guys
comments resonate
it's really about quality being able to
trust the data you know
it's taking that complex information and
being able to use that to support those
precisions diagnosis uh there and
interpretations
so i want to ask one final question here
as we wrap up i apologize
so you know looking at our audience here
who's come to learn about the knowledge
bases and the different types and how
they're curated
you know what's your advice to them in
terms of you know what to look for when
choosing a database
to support their interpretation needs
yeah absolutely
so i mean um in terms of the
interpretation
i'd say you you want to you know use
a database that you uh are pretty
certain that you know it has that
reputation that the content has been
invested
right so there might be databases that
pop
up you know every so often but sometimes
they don't have the longevity they don't
have
that reputation and i've unfortunately
you know
encountered customers who their
pipelines uh totally were outdated
because
they chose a database that was very new
and it was not
kept up to speed essentially um so just
ensuring that you have
the quality but i think also the
reputation that goes with it
ensuring that the database is going to
be updated frequently
because we do see you know for
hereditary cases that
you know every six months is a good rule
of thumb to take a look at the brand
classification to ensure that nothing
has changed
and whether you're doing clinical
testing or you're producing a
publication
you of course want to make sure that you
know you have to
the accurate information whenever you're
putting
those signed in substations on your your
report
or your paper so i think it is important
to just
make sure you have the quality there all
around and really
going with a database that you can trust
that has the reputation
to back it up yeah
yeah definitely and especially um in
some of these spaces
um around the timeliness of the update
so
um if you're you know if you're reliant
upon a
a workflow if if your workflow's
integrated with a
a database and um you know you're you're
not able to get the information
as quickly as as you know is needed to
do your reports then you're gonna have
to come up with you know
workarounds and things like that and
it's gonna it's gonna probably
quickly eat away at any efficiencies
that you have so the with the
qci interpret the kyogen knowledge base
we're updating constantly we roll out
content updates to our applications
uh roughly weekly so you know when that
new drug approval or a
guideline update happens you have access
to that
information from that reputable source
rapidly so that you're able to you know
to pivot quickly on
any new development or a drug approval
that has occurred you know when
once the in truck inhibitors when the
first intra inhibitor became
uh was approved you know that obviously
was something that
you know for patients that had cancers
where that would have been applicable
you want to be able to report that out
quickly and use it in your standard
workflow
so all right simon
yeah and i'd agree with all of that uh
quality
obviously is something we've all agreed
on on that across this discussion
i think in addition uh does the
information that you're looking at does
the database provide that data
at high enough resolution i think um
there are a lot of resources trying to
describe
the you know this kind of information
across
high-level annotations it's easy to see
a range of mutations in lung cancer or
blood cancer
but you only get meaningful
interpretations when you're looking at
very specific types of blood cancer for
instance
and those very specific types need to be
almost
the kind of thing a hematologist might
see once or twice in a career
but by putting together large numbers of
case studies across those
instances you get really clear pictures
and very high resolution pictures of
what matters genetically
and then of course standard hair
principles apply
um is this data provided
in in good quality standardized
annotations are you using standard
genotypic uh genomic annotations are you
using
good vocabularies and of course
is it easy to take that data and plug it
into your workflow as sean says
no one looks at millions of mutations in
isolation it's plugged into something
else
um therefore it's got to be annotated in
a useful way to
uh to plug into something else and the
quality of the annotation and the
interoperability of the data
uh are vital when you're looking at
databases of the scale we're discussing
today
all right fantastic so thank you uh to
the panelists here i wanted to sort of
you know pull this to a conclusion here
but
i mean we set out with a topic powering
the precision in uh precision medicine
i i think you know the key that you've
heard from the panelists here is
you know the size of the panels whole
genome the complexity of the information
here
you know knowledge bases are going to
become more and more important
and centralized access to high quality
trusted
information is going to become more and
more important as we
we start to scale in this world of
precision medicine if we're to get that
7 out of 10 45 of people up into that
high level of confidence
you know to deliver that precision
medicine you know there's got to be more
adoption and use of these you know high
quality
knowledge bases going forward so big
thank you for
attending this uh webinar today uh thank
you to the panelists
this concludes the session for today
thank you
thank you thanks